Hokkaido is the second largest island in Japan.
It only has 5% of the population of the country,...
...so it's mainly countryside and mountains and really great landscapes to look at.
Hokkaido is covered with national parks and the major one is Daisetsuzan.
People know about skiing in Hokkaido.
What they don't know is in the summer,...
...it's a great outdoor adventure place...
...for whitewater rafting, for mountain biking, for fishing.
The Japanese, when they like to relax, they go to an onsen,...
...an outdoor hot spring,...
...and Hokkaido is covered with these.
The outside and the nature surrounded by the trees and the mountains...
...is a wonderful way to experience the country.